welcome to this video playing GMD GMD 13
have from Greece yeah okay let's see
what is aiming for the Dutch defense
okay I don't really want the g three
setups so let's play something like that
okay okay get this Bishop Jack and he
will have from the sort of hybrid Dutch
nums Oh type of position I get some some
space here and one idea here author
sugar played b5 actually put play b5
here and why not
he could what I was trying to say is so
that if you tell if I would have not
played be five he has the idea to play
be five that's an interesting way to to
handle the position let's see I don't
want to castle yet give him giving him
some clear target 94 we have six these
types of moves yeah but it's hard to
delay that for for for like forever
castles yeah okay 5v5 is awesome well
that's that's very very direct yeah so I
have two basic ideas against I can play
92 to exchange or I can complain I t1
intending f3 and this is what I'm trying
to do
so f 3 here where is he going after that
Knight f6 I can take a five jump I can
take a five I don't really see why I
shouldn't yeah yeah and I thought just
to h3 and that's it sorry
92 we effort that I can go to after
where I really don't think there is
something going on or is there something
better but just briefly think about it I
don't think so that's almost trapped
that's almost dragged if I go Bishop d3
bishops is or bishop CA to thread
bishops eh could be a threat but I can
go to h6 the others should save the day
okay here i don't really see how it can
attack me anymore ok ok then this night
is hanging I mean look a 3 trap set I
can take on the form ok
I can take g5 with check it's the sir
something that I should do maybe what I
should do definitely should do is to
play a bit cool down okay come on just
and it's let's use this long diagonal I
mean this is like a really nice diagonal
I don't mind the exchange hundreds and
just trying to open up this Bishop don't
be too it has only has it so this
position looks a bit like there are
maybe some technical liabilities cannot
really say what but it looks like a bit
a bit of my my pieces but I needed to
believe it to play needed to play a move
takes maybe just takes can maybe take on
a form actually I cannot play rook takes
Queen III is a bit too much okay yeah I
can take a plane I'd f3m this diagonal
is quite something
check yeah that's that's nice now
everything's very neatly protected I've
got three pawns for the exchange don't
want him to counter counter sec not not
at the moment it's a very nicely
coordinated so just want to push the
pawns
check
time warning ya know I can't read the
rook no problem
attending a five check and then the
pawns roll check check jam one that's
these pawns should promote really I can
counter sacrifice I probably should
prevent that make it not make my life
more complicated I wanted to play Bishop
f4 but then there is Rooker look at five
hmm Bishop age 6 yeah I think I'm still
winning but check it was a wasn't good a
good technical play what's to but too
relaxed here
yeah that was really rubbish I shouldn't
have given all the pawns maybe yet some
some way to save it really possible
oh okay no move yeah maybe I really I
really screwed it up I mean I gave up a
bit too many pawns I thought that the
combination of bishop and pawns
basically promote them promotes easily
may be disconnected black4 fits on time
no one time okay let's let's check this
did I did I really screw this up I it's
the win it's still a win but probably
not Bishop g7 as the move okay and this
is losing you to today rook takes deform
great great i miscounted really i cannot
stop the porn yeah I'm just sended yet
right and it was totally unnecessary I
mean like here if you if you just keep
looks on the board and then push
nothing's happening here very easy very
easy win jalna that was really bad plane
around here this is like very easily
winning yeah I wonder if maybe I'm sorry
check maybe I had something better here
rookie Brooke a 3m probably still rookie
rookie what's a bit irritated by all
that but there is really nothing going
on this is really nothing happening ok
yeah ok but then basically Queen takes a
five and all this is totally unplayable
maybe I can take on d4 mother that's
that's maybe an idea
yeah that's not so clear it's still very
very messy position but the bad thing
was that I really managed to to screw
this end game up oh wow alright thanks
for watching